تحدي جديد امام ترامب اذا صدرت مذكره
اعتقال بحقه في غياب سابقه بامريكا فمن
الجهه التي ستنفذ الاعتقال بين السلطات
انفاذ القانون وجهاز الخدمه السريه اما
التحدي الثاني كيف ستكون طريقه اعتقال
ترامب وهل سيتم تقييده حرس ترامب الخاص
يقول انه مسؤول قانونيا عن امن الرئيس اذ
يتمتع الرئيس الامريكي السابق وعائلته
بحراسه كامله لمده عشر سنوات
فالرئيس السابق لا يستطيع التحرك خارج
اقامته دون مرافقه جهاز الحراسه الخاص به
كما يراقب الحرس الخاص هواتف الرؤساء
السابقين تحسبا لاي تهديد ويفحص الرسائل
والطروض الموجهه باسمائهم بينما سلطات
انفاذ القانون تقول انها المسؤوله عن
الاعتقال في القضايا الجنائيه وان عمليه
الاعتقاد تتضمن تقييد الرئيس واخذ بصماته
وصوره لوجهه
كما تتولى عمليه نقل ترامب للمحكمه